warning the following program contain
scenes of snobbery rudeness and mass
murder yeah fewer discretion is advised
that doesn't make any goddamn sense uh
yeah hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome to we become what
we behold this is made by the same
creator of the game and you may remember
the game from a while ago as a flash
animated Style game about memes and such
back when they weren't actually memes
and such because that game came out in
2008.
this guy I got another profound to say
about that 2008 what happened in 2008
here's what happened what happened in
2008
oh that's right the financial crisis
that's what the game was all about if
you want to know about the game I'll put
a link in the description it was great I
loved it a lot uh but this is a short
five minute
Adventure about something we become what
we behold we shape our tools and then
our tools shape us someone call Wade he
needs to do a lot of shaping oh hello
Point click alrighty then why hello sir
[Music]
yay
[Music]
oh oh
really
oh no way so it would definitely want me
to take a picture of that but I don't
want it this guy what has he done just a
normal people just a NASA people oh okay
so what I'm oh crank it oh hey okay
gotta catch him doing something
interesting oh all righty then
well you gonna do something
crazy Square attacks oh geez oh yeah you
should be worried oh God did I just
skirt over the love oh hey what Circle
fear squares okay
all righty then
um
oops man I really am controlling Destiny
here this is too much power for me to
hold on to huh
squares snub circles as they should
they've been fearful oh no oh no oh geez
oh God
I didn't mean to avoid that I meant to
actually catch that in the act of it I'm
sorry you love birds I've just been
oh oh
come on who Tunes in to watch people get
along I do oh that's adorable oh it's
adorable
piece is boring violence goes viral I
feel like there's a message to be said
here
look at him he's so happy
oh you yell all you want look at this
guy are you yelling blood
I think you are actually hey wanna I
wanna see if this guy is ever going to
yell at this guy here because that's
really going to be the headline here oh
no he's a rampaging screamer somebody
stop him he's screaming on the internet
someone stop him come on you're right
there come on come on
[Music]
oh come on got it nailed it Circle hates
squares well uh-oh well that's no good
that's a lot of yelling
does no one going to yell at this guy
all right fine man
we'll hang up I see how it is oh
oh so I gotta I gotta catch Square yell
in a circle there we go Square hates
circles oh no oh no
oh no love yes love love and every story
needs a conflict so oh no
don't yell at that Cricket you just
yelled at the cricket oh no love learn
to love why can't you guys get along
stop screaming for one second oh geez
almost everyone hates everyone oh geez
oh no I get the message I do I get it oh
everyone hates everyone that's not what
I wanted out of this experience
oh no what about the love
love hello you have a lovely hat are you
gonna do something
it's Destiny
oh
[Applause]
whoa whoa
what the [ __ ] this took a dark turn
oh
oh be scared be angry oh oh God
oh it is oh God stop it
stop it oh geez oh God okay all right
there's no winning here now I done bad
oh God I did something bad oh geez
oh boy
I didn't want to do this I didn't want
anything to do with this oh geez oh god
oh geez oh god oh
holy [ __ ] that went wrong real quick
wow
oh wow oh
my goodness
holy [ __ ]
that was uh
that rendered me speechless you all
understand the message correct oh God
that's so sad
oh no
oh my God
it's so nice just lovely oh man that's
the end oh that's awesome
share the pain oh God share the pain oh
man I I I get the message it's just the
constant cycle of of negativity because
it it creates interest is a bad cycle to
perpetuate it's just a horrible cycle to
keep going because it's just something
it's the snake that eats its own tail
it's the constant never-ending wheel of
pain if you constantly tell people that
the world is horrible they will
eventually believe you and then
you will become a prophet because what
you said shall become true oof there's
too many parallels to draw into society
today so I won't draw them myself I will
spread positivity and you know what
that's actually a good idea I want to go
spread joy and love and happiness and
freedom so I'm gonna go out there and I
don't know how I'm going to do it but
I'm going to spread a lot of joy and a
lot of happiness and show you some
really cool heartwarming things because
I think that's the antidote we need for
this right now not that this game was
bad this game was incredible and I loved
it a lot and I really do respect what
this developer does
she does an amazing job so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
next video bye-bye
[Music]